有时候在想，
如果我提前去世了，
我希望我的孩子不要因为说他的爸爸能重新获到幸福而变得心里不痛快，
因为在我的心里的话，
可能我的儿子他自己的日子过得好，
他自己的事业发展的好，
他自己心理健康，
身体健康，
每天都高高兴兴的过日子，
才是我最想看到的。
我妈妈是2023年，
就五月份我离世了嘛，
患了癌症三年之后呢，
我爸爸就是找个阿姨，
这个阿姨的情况有点复杂，
她是我妈妈的舅舅家的儿媳妇介绍的，
她的舅妈就相当于是我妈妈娘家的亲戚介绍，
这从子女的角度来讲呢，
可能感情上有一些不愿意接受，
但是还是允许让我爸谈自己的一个选择嘛，
但当时出了一个事情，
他们认识嘛，
认识之后，
娘家的这些他们那帮那个亲戚就说可能要我爸表示一下什么的，
我爸说那就买个金项链嘛，
你觉得可能也太少了，
那样买个青镯子，
但我爸当时可能没有想那么多，
就把我妈那个金镯子就置换了，
不过这个事儿呢，
我就着急闹了一场，
而且只有在半年前发生的事情，
现在出了个什么事么，
就不是过了半年嘛，
过了半年之后，
阿姨和那个爸爸还是在一起的，
在上个星期阿姨的这个孩子结婚，
他们其实是外地的嘛，
也办了婚礼的，
我爸又在我们家给这个继子办婚礼，
还请了28周，
我这时候就很生气嘛，
因为我是不同意办。
我就会去说这个事情，
但他们还是办了，
结果就开始在吵在闹，
这样子，
现在我的问题是什么呢？
因为之前其实没有想，
这可能都是一些感情的事情，
现在可能就想的是，
哎，
当时我结婚的时候给了我一套，
那我自己住了一套，
另外一套是他们住着的，
这套房子呢，
相当于现在应该是我爸的名字，
我没看过房产证啊，
我就有点这个想法，
因为他肯定是要诚实一家人嘛，
他们才能办这个酒，
有可能我怀疑他们是不是领证了，
这是第一个事情，
第二个事情，
我现在就想把这个房子过户回来，
就是起码得给我，
而且我当然我妈走了之后，
我还有个亲姐比我大8岁，
我每个月还给我爸4000块钱的生活费，
那为什么给呢？
就因为觉得他们已经太辛苦了，
希望他们不要那么辛苦，
就让我爸就出去旅游啊，
什么玩一下，
或者找个保姆什么的，
照顾他一下嘛，
对不对，
这样子，
那天我爸办完酒之后呢，
他们就和阿姨哈，
还有一个继子就出去旅游了，
我情绪上就很激动，
回来我去要这个房子，
我就打电话，
我爸说以后再说，
就和我姐说，
然后姐开始嘛，
觉得还是嫁出去的女儿就回去要房子也不好，
因为我已经拿了一套房子，
就我结婚的时候我们还没见上面，
我姐给我爸打电话，
我爸的大概的意思呢，
把房子可以过户，
因为我们要求要么家里要么过户嘛，
我爸只要要么就给一点钱过户，
就把它过户给我姐夫，
给我这个的钱是多少呢？
现在大概比如说20万，
因为那个房子现在市价的话，
应该是能够值个六七十万。
那肯定是值得了的，
我就问他为什么要给这个钱，
他的意思呢，
这也是你妈有份，
他们自己留的钱养老，
大概就这个意思，
那你要给20万钱的这个房子，
他的意思就直接过户给我后，
给我姐，
谁际要谁又把这个钱给了。
之前我们家不是买保险嘛，
就是有我大的保险，
他每年可能交1万多，
这一直是他们交的，
这两年是我交的，
我可能交一万二吧，
一年马上还有两年就到了，
这个钱他是储蓄的那种，
保险是储蓄，
他可以一起一拖就提出来，
或者说按照分月的给他，
这种大概也有个20多吧，
那天我去查了一下，
不到25，
再加上我爸之前我结婚，
我妈的妈妈走右，
我外婆走，
就这接半酒都是我爸在做，
手上肯定是拿了有些钱的，
现在我第一个问题就是如果他结婚了，
这个房子好不好说，
第二个就是这些钱，
他那个保险，
那个受益人是他本人，
因为他没过世嘛，
是他的，
如果他一要是他的话，
也很具体啊，
这个事情我在想的，
我怎么去谈和怎么去沟通，
其实我最开始是没想要这个房子的，
我们都是自己创业，
我姐老公对她也很好，
我姐夫条件也很好，
我和我姐关系很好，
我自己也是自己创业，
能够把自己养活，
娶得那个媳妇儿，
他家条件也很好，
大家没有自己去想过那个房子的事儿，
但现在我心里面就有一点，
你这样一会儿搞这个事儿，
就是搞那个事儿，
而且我感觉我爸是非常喜欢那个阿姨的，
所以这个房子我想要过户回来，
现在这个钱怎么给，
那我肯定是不同意给这20万的。
那他就说以后再说，
我觉得闹也不是个事儿，
你知道吗？
闹来闹去就吵，
心情这方面又要出来说，
很浪费我的情绪，
现在我想怎么快速的把这个事儿解决，
而且他如果领证了之后，
这个事儿会不会对后期有点影响，
大概的情况就是这样，
我之前好像在哪里看到过这个事件，
有可能就你的这个事情，
把妈妈生前用的金镯子，
在妈妈去世了之后，
把这个金镯子拿去置换给了新的老婆，
这个事情肯定是你爸爸做的不妥的，
因为这个金镯子从法律上来说的话，
他也是你妈妈的遗物，
从情感上来说的话，
他也是伴随着你妈妈走过了这些岁月的，
这样一个有感情寄托的东西，
你爸爸这么做肯定是不妥的，
爸他肯定是做错了，
而且我在我家我是比较强势的，
因为我不需要靠任何人，
所以当时我一定要套手公皂，
因为我们是有很多，
比如说金镯子啊，
金项链什么的，
像我爸就拿了一些，
我拿了一些，
我妈我没有拿，
大部分给我姐姐了，
于为这些东西我们不在嘛，
对不对吧，
当时我也没有拿，
拿了个戒指吧，
我记得相当于我爸当时就认为那是给他的，
他是可以自己处理的，
到后面他也认了嘛，
说这个事儿是他做的不妥，
当时就可能没思考那么多，
当时都是不愿意道歉的，
后面被我压的没办法，
我就说如果不道歉，
这个阿姨肯定是她不了的，
从那个时候我就发现，
其实他从内心来讲，
我是能感受到他是喜欢这个阿姨的，
她是想照顾。
他保护他也好，
你为当时我的最后一个条件就是我不反对你，
比如说你要找老伴，
但是我反对你这样的做法，
后面他还是认了，
这个事儿不道歉了，
那这个事儿咱们就翻篇了啊，
对，
至于说这个阿姨，
你跟他接触了之后，
你觉得阿姨这个人是怎么样的一个人呢？
君子任气不人心吗？
就反正有两个事已经摆在眼前了，
就他是怎么样的人，
我不说那起把继子办酒这个事是办了嘛，
对吧？
继子办酒这个事情钱是你的爸爸出的吗？
对呀，
肯定是我爸出的嘛，
叫的是我家的亲戚，
他们相当于在自己的老家办了一场，
办了18桌我亲的，
我不知道，
我家还办了个20多桌我家的亲戚戚吃的酒，
再加上这个阿姨又是我妈妈连后家的嘛，
所以他我妈妈家有些亲戚，
反正就相当于凑齐了，
那我认为你爸爸确实是对这个阿姨可能是上头了，
确实啊，
因为这两年吧，
我可能也回家三次吧，
有时候吃过饭啊，
过年那些，
我知子莫路父嘛，
因为我后爸始终30多年的父子，
我其实特别了解他，
他是一个特别会端水的，
装傻的，
他不会和我凶，
不会和我闹，
但是他自己是我觉得是很聪明的，
这个事情，
那个房子的事儿，
其实前就提过，
其实我们都不在乎，
在家都有什么，
你无所谓，
但现在他为什么要钱，
我就那天和我姐分析，
他俩都领没领证，
现在还是个未知数，
对不对，
又不好问，
他说没领，
那是时候你不领他就了。
我就这样想，
他办酒办的是他儿子的酒，
不是他俩的酒吗？
不是他儿子的结婚酒，
不是他俩的酒。
这样我先跟你讲一下，
如果他俩领证，
将来会有什么影响好不好？
好的，
谢谢。
因为你之前也请过律师了，
可能大体也了解一些，
如果他俩领证了，
你的父亲名下的这一套价值60万的房产，
实际上他是你的父亲和你的母亲的共同资产，
你的母亲去世的时候并没有对这套房进行一个析产，
所以这套房里面还有你母亲的一半，
60万当中30万是你母亲遗留下来的，
这30万应该有你母亲的法定继承人来平均的继承。
法定的继承人我不知道你母亲的父母还在不在，
没有了啊，
母亲的父母如果不在的话，
就是配偶和子女来平均分割，
也就是说你和你姐姐一人能分到10万块钱，
在这个房子里面的利益是这样的，
如果说你的父亲以后结了婚，
结了婚了之后呢？
因为这套房产是你父亲的婚前的个人财产，
所以这套房产是不会因为他们领证而变成他们俩的夫妻共同财产的。
但是如果你的父亲死在前面，
而那个阿姨还活着，
而他们俩又领了证，
那么你父亲去世之后，
你父亲在这套房产上的份额。
就会发生一次法定的继承，
如果他不写什么遗嘱的话，
那那个时候阿姨是作为一个其中的继承人和你以及你的姐姐，
包括如果你有爷爷奶奶的话，
又来一起来平分你父亲名下在这套房当中所占据的比例，
按照现在来说的话，
你父亲在60万的房子里面，
他占40万，
如果他死在前面，
这40万又会发生一轮继承，
你看吧，
就要20万，
我跟你讲真的是，
其实从法律上来说的话，
你给他20万把这个房产过户到你的名下是划算的，
为什么呢？
因为从法律上来说的话，
你和你的姐姐各自只能分到10万块钱，
保险呢，
保险肯定是他的嘛，
他这个保险要到了有20多保险是属于他的财产，
如果说这个保险是在他们夫妻存续期间去投的保，
那么这个保险当中也有一部分财产是你妈妈的，
有一半对是你妈妈的，
但这个保险如果说最终的利益是20万的话，
其中有10万块钱应该算是你妈妈的，
但是也是你和你的父亲和你的姐姐去平均去享受你妈妈的这个利益嘛，
那可能到你的头上可能就是3万块钱左右，
所以我觉得保险这个事情就随他去，
你爸爸他自己到时间了，
受益人是他自己的话，
就他自己领了就可以了，
捐房子的事情可以也是划算的。
都这样算对，
我觉得是划算的，
但我给你出个主意，
你说爸，
我现在创业阶段啊，
钱比较紧张，
我先给你一部分，
我过两年再给你一部分，
我给你打欠条都行，
因为我家呢，
一直是我姐条件还不错，
我比较能挣，
家里面她是知道我情况的，
因为那天我打他电话讲了嘛，
她说我也知道你现在的意思，
怕这个房子，
或者我和阿姨结婚，
就她结婚这个事，
我是阻止不了的，
那我再怎么闹，
我不能天天闹嘛，
对，
而且我是个男的，
我能天天去，
对也阻止不了，
对阻止不了嘛，
从利益上我说实话，
10万20万啊，
我觉得我是可以的，
就你说20万，
我可以拿，
我姐拿，
拿给他我也没问题，
那是我姐弟俩的事儿，
但我从心里面讲，
我觉得他太幸福了，
从做妈妈的这个角度，
从母亲这个角度的话，
其实我能理解你就觉得你的妈妈没有过上什么好日子，
没有做到什么该得到有多幸福，
但是却被另外一个陌生的女人得到了你妈妈该有的幸福，
我理解你，
但是他的幸福太张扬了，
感情上你知道吗？
我就想使唤，
我就想打扰，
你知道吗？
除了闹其实也没什么办法，
而且我觉得我爸就真的是因为太了解我爸了，
他会是一个什么样的状态，
在这种情感面前的状态是什么？
因为那么多年了，
所以这个时候我心里面是非常的不舒服的。
然后还有生活费的事情，
我当时我谈了嘛，
我就在想，
那生活费可以就不拿了，
因为他自己本来要退休金，
可能有3000多块钱嘛，
生活费我们一个月还给4000，
比如说我都给了你20万了。
我说给了10万，
那你生活费是不是可以减半，
或者不拿了，
就直接这个生活费是给他的，
你要出去玩也好，
你要用也好，
无所谓，
就把你钱照顾你，
但你现在确实说你两个人过，
我觉得是这样，
生活费可以不给了，
换成买东西，
我就给我爸买鞋，
就给我爸买羽绒服，
就给我爸买皮带，
就给我爸买手机，
就给我爸买成按摩椅，
就换成买东西就好了，
那这个钱的话先给吧，
你后面再说。
对呀，
我多几句嘴，
不知道你今年是多大的年纪了，
我有时候在想，
如果我提前去世了，
我希望我的孩子不要因为说他的爸爸能重新获到幸福而变得心里不痛快，
因为在我的心里的话，
可能我的儿子他自己的日子过得好，
他自己的事业发展的好，
他自己心理健康，
身体健康，
每天都高高兴兴的过日子才是我最想看到的，
而且还有我并不觉得我的孩子用这种方式去维护我的利益，
我会觉得高兴，
我并不觉得高兴，
我觉得我的孩子如果说能够通过我的离开了之后，
更加珍惜他自己的生活，
珍惜他自己的老婆，
珍惜他自己的孩子相处的时光的话，
我会更开心。
这可能也是，
其实我还好，
我其实我自己其实知道自己在做什么的，
工作也好啊，
生活也好啊，
不处理事，
我还是情感和情感。
利归利益这样子，
但是你说一点影响都没有吗？
肯定我觉得需要时间嘛，
并竟且两年的时间。
回归到现实的话，
利一我觉得这样可以去处理，
就不指望他那个东西能够给我带来多少的收益，
能够给我制造多少财富，
但从情感上来讲，
我觉得起码就是阿姨要和他在一起，
起码对这个家的尊重，
他要记住我爸也得是因为之前做的事儿也好，
或者说现在你爸有这个事儿也好，
我觉得就有点对我来讲，
我说感情上是有伤害的，
其实我不允许因为我过的难受，
说他们干嘛要过得开心的，
他们都那么幸福，
你的难受更大一部分是基于心疼自己的妈妈，
更大一部分是基于为妈妈打抱不平。
但是我想告诉你，
其实你的妈妈需要的不是你为她打抱不平，
需要的是你过好你自己的日子，
需要的是你珍惜你现在拥有的一切，
这我肯定是能够理解的。
情感的事我觉得再说吧，
那我觉得情感需要的时间吧，
嗯，
确实环境在这个地方可能要继己续面对钱的事儿，
其实最好就还是拿过来，
还是过过来，
是的，
房子够过来更划算，
一算账你就能算明白了啊，
就给一半看，
先沟通，
对，
以后再说其他的对，
好的，
谢谢，
不谢啊，
再见，
谢谢大家啊，
谢谢，
我能理解，
作为儿女啊，
尤其是自己的妈妈提前过世了，
爸爸在很短的时间半年之内就找对象，
这个事儿，
甚至有的可能3个月2个月半。
这个月就开始找对象，
甚至有的是妈妈那头刚埋下去这一头，
爸爸找的对象就已经住进了妈妈以前的房子里了。
我其实能理解大家心里的这种痛苦，
就觉得妈妈一辈子省吃俭用的，
不舍得给自己买好的衣服，
不舍得给自己吃，
干了这些家业，
凭什么让另外一个女人来享受这些呢？
我能理解大家，
但如果是我的话，
反正我已经死了，
反正我已经不在这个世界上了，
我是不愿意看到我的孩子因为这些事情而痛苦的。
所以以后我会第一绝不亏待自己，
在我活着的时候，
我想吃什么，
想穿什么，
想用什么，
想住什么样的房子的话，
我一定先满足我自己，
我绝不亏待我自己，
绝不让我的孩子觉得我这一辈子可不容易了，
可亏待自己了，
不，
我要让我的孩子觉得我这辈子过得可好了，
没有什么遗憾，
没有什么亏欠，
如果我走在前面的话，
我是能接受我的对象，
赶紧找个老伴儿吧，
我能接受，
我可能也就现在这个心态能接受。
也不知道说我老了，
真到生命的尽头的时候，
我会不会变得自私，
变得更纯真一点，
因为我看到有一个网红法官爷爷，
就是美国的吧，
他老是在法庭上会给出一些罚单，
有的时候会给出一些捐赠，
他在临终的时候，
他说那句话我一直记得，
就是请你们记住我，
我心想这样一个德高望重的，
那么温情的，
觉悟这么高的。
一个老人，
在他离开这个世界的时候，
居然那么纯真，
那么简单，
还想大家能记住我，
记得点赞关注哦。